STEPHANIE WONG: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
Managing Costs in GCP:
How to Structure
Your Resources, then
stay tuned, because
here's a rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Whether
you're a solo developer
or a multinational corporation,
there's a good chance
that you're looking for
a transparent, simple,
and predictable way to manage
your costs in the cloud.
Luckily, Google Cloud Platform
gives you a simple way
to organize your resources
to make billing and cost
optimization a lot easier
for your cloud projects.
Let's start with projects,
which are GCP's basic organizing
entity and form the
basis for using all GCP
services, including
managing APIs,
enabling billing, adding
and removing collaborators,
managing permissions,
and other metadata that
describes your workloads.
You also have a
billing account, which
defines who pays for
projects and resources.
Each project has a
single billing account
which defines roles and
permissions and, of course,
manages payments.
Next, let's talk about labels.
Those are ad hoc
key value pairs that
are assigned to resources,
like VMs and GCS buckets, which
are categorized in
billing, so that you
can assign specific cost centers
or teams to foot the bill.
Now, for those of you who need
more fine-grained reporting
and details, you'll want to
look into enabling the BigQuery
billing exports.
This will export your
invoices as tables
into BigQuery, our large-scale
analytics platform.
Why?
You gain incredible
reporting capabilities
at a low cost with extremely
granular data about your usage
of Google Cloud Platform.
While you do get an
invoice every month,
investigating particular
cost drivers and trends using
the BigQuery export
helps you understand
every nuance of every cost.
It lets you use
familiar SQL to slice
and dice your billing data
for powerful analysis.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link
in the description
below, and don't forget to
subscribe to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]